cuál de las siguientes gráficas puede
representar a la hipérbola de cuadrado
entre 9 - x cuadrada entre 4 igual a 1
muy bien entonces si nos damos cuenta
que en este ejercicio tenemos cuatro
opciones de gráficas que podrían en
principio representar a esta ecuación de
la hipérbola verdad entonces por ejemplo
podemos ver que la opción a y la opción
c son hiper bolas que abren hacia arriba
y hacia abajo verdad es decir en la
dirección vertical mientras que la
hipérbola
y la hipérbola de son hiper bolas que
abren en la dirección horizontal verdad
entonces podemos ver además que también
tienen distintos vértices entonces
tenemos hay varias opciones para poder
determinar cuál de éstas corresponde a
esta ecuación así que te invito a que
hagas una pausa y trates de resolver
este problema por tu cuenta trata de
descubrir cuál es la gráfica apropiada
que representa esta ecuación de la
hipérbola
entonces bueno hay muchas formas de
resolver el problema una por ejemplo
sería determinar cuál es el centro y si
vemos la forma de la ecuación podríamos
descubrir fácilmente que el centro es el
origen es decir el punto con coordenadas
0,0 en realidad nosotros podríamos por
ejemplo poner que el centro primero
sería un punto de la forma h acá verdad
digamos esas serían sus sus coordenadas
pero de ser así entonces la forma de la
ecuación tendría que ser de la siguiente
de la siguiente forma sería ye menos acá
al cuadrado dividido entre 9 menos x
menos h al cuadrado dividido entre 4
igual a 1 verdad entonces podríamos
decir bueno pues entonces para que sea
igual a esta forma que tenemos acá
tendría que ser 0 y h tendría que ser 0
lo cual querría decir que el centro
tiene que ser el punto 0,0 verdad y aquí
podemos ver qué
en todas estas opciones el centro es
justamente el origen verdad del 0 0
entonces bueno eso no nos ayuda mucho
para descubrir cuál de estas cuatro
tiene que ser verdad así que vamos a ver
la siguiente pregunta será que esta
hipérbola abre hacia arriba y hacia
abajo o bien abre hacia la derecha y a
la izquierda es decir abre en la
dirección vertical o en la dirección
horizontal y la clave para descubrir
esto es analizar el signo de los
términos que lleva y que llevan x y el
signo del término que lleva verdad es
decir por ejemplo veamos aquí el signo
positivo lo lleva el término con la
variable de verdad entonces esto nos
garantiza que la hipérbola va a abrir
hacia arriba y hacia abajo se verá
más o menos así verdad de hecho el signo
menos corresponde al término en xy y por
supuesto uno uno se preguntaría bueno y
por qué es que el signo positivo en la
variable que determina que abre hacia
arriba y hacia abajo bueno no sé ustedes
para mí siempre me gusta tratar de ver
porque esto es así y no de otra forma lo
que podríamos hacer es primero tratar de
anular este término y para anular este
término
simplemente tendríamos que darle el
valor de x a la coordenada x del centro
es decir en este caso hacer x igual a h
para que este término completo
desaparezca verdad entonces en este caso
podríamos hacer x igual a cero vamos a
hacerlo si nosotros tenemos que x es
igual a cero entonces este término se
cancela verdad y simplemente nos queda
que cuadrada sobre 9 tiene que ser igual
a 1
o bien simplemente podríamos multiplicar
de ambos lados por 9 y tendremos que
cuadrada es igual a 9 verdad entonces
sigue cuadrada es igual a 9 podríamos
concluir que ya tiene que ser más o
menos 3 verdad simplemente sacando raíz
cuadrada lo cual quiere decir que
tenemos 2 puntos tenemos el 0 3 y el
0,23 verdad y estos dos puntos se
encuentran sobre la hipérbola verdad por
ejemplo aquí en este y pérgolas y
tenemos el punto 0 - 0 3 y el 0,3 en
cambio aquí no lo tenemos verdad aquí
está el 0 3 y el 0 menos tres y
claramente no se encuentran sobre la
hipérbola y esto esto se puede analizar
en general verdad de hecho también
podemos observar que no vamos a
interceptar el eje x no vamos a
interceptar
eje x ok pues por ejemplo si hacemos
ahora de igual a cero es decir le damos
el valor de acá a nuestra variable y
entonces qué es lo que tendríamos esta
primer parte se cancela y sólo nos
quedaría menos equis cuadrada sobre 4 es
igual a 1 así que si multiplicamos por
menos 1 tendríamos x cuadrado entre 4
igual a menos 1 multiplicando por menos
uno de ambos lados luego multiplicamos
por cuatro de ambos lados y tendremos x
cuadrada igual a menos 4 y podemos ver
que no hay solución es verdad por eso es
que nuestra hipérbola no interese acá al
eje x verdad entonces por ejemplo en
este caso si intersec al eje x y por eso
es que esta no es una opción para la
hipérbola bien en general diríamos que
la hipérbola no cruza la línea
horizontal que tiene altura que tiene la
misma altura que el centro bien y
entonces también ya sabemos que bueno
aquí le dijimos que los puntos
30 - tres son vértices de la hipérbola
verdad entonces podemos ver que aquí si
es que aquí sí estaban sin embargo aquí
por ejemplo no se encuentran sobre la
hipérbola verdad aunque aunque abre
hacia arriba y hacia abajo por supuesto
éste tampoco esté aquí en este ejemplo
tampoco están así que podemos estar muy
seguros de que nuestra opción a es la
respuesta correcta esta es la gráfica
que representa a esta hipérbola